dr bethany moore was exhausted she'd
been pulling an all-nighter to digitize
some old files about scp-2317
the door to another world and she could
feel herself nodding off little by
little as the night drew on for dr moore
it'd been a whole week of long days
something even worse when you work at a
job as stressful as being a researcher
for the scp foundation and the exertion
was starting to catch up with her at
around 2 30 am she sighed rolled back
her office chair and decided to take a
quick break to grab a coffee and refuel
if she didn't get some pretty hardcore
caffeine in her over the next few
minutes she was absolutely going to pass
out on her keyboard the fact that the
rooms in the facility were kept at a
relatively low light at this time of
night to save power really wasn't
helping her fatigue dr moore dragged
herself down to the break room too tired
and too focused on her work to notice
that things were eerily quiet
she was punching in her order for the
largest espresso available when she
noticed the quiet sound of footsteps
approaching her from behind slow
methodical and unsettling especially at
this kind of hour she turned and felt an
immense relief wash over her it was just
security officer chuck walker one of the
regular guards at this site dr moore and
security officer walker weren't exactly
best friends but they'd cross paths on
the job on numerous occasions and they'd
always been polite friendly and cordial
any time they directly interacted hey
check she said while her coffee began to
pour into the less than environmentally
friendly styrofoam cup behind her long
night working hard or hardly working huh
security officer walker didn't respond
it was only now that dr moore seemed to
register just how dark the break room
was really the only source of light was
the soft glow coming from the coffee
machine itself but light or no light she
could see something was wrong with
walker his eyes seemed oddly distant
like he wasn't even looking at her he
was looking through her off into some
unknown place dr moore cleared her
throat everything okay cha before she
could even finish her sentence chuck's
hands were clasped around her throat the
movement was so sudden and violent her
back was shoved up against the coffee
machine spilling the espresso everywhere
she tried to scream but she couldn't get
enough air chuck squeezed his grip was
like an iron around her thin neck she
silently gasped and spluttered as he
choked her still maintaining that glassy
almost dead look in his eye like doing
this meant absolutely nothing to him as
things started to go dark dr moore's
thoughts were naturally along the lines
of why is he doing this to me and that's
exactly when she got her answer there
were two eyes that seemed almost to be
floating in the darkness behind security
officer walker staring with equal
indifference at this sudden and awful
display of meaningless violence she
could only just make out the slender
shape of the creature's mostly obsidian
body with the occasional patch of white
it was her it all made sense now it all
made so much sense the daughter of snap
dr moore's neck broke leaving her last
thought forever unfinished security
officer walker loosened his grip
allowing dr moore's body to slump to the
ground he turned to his mistress for
approval but she didn't say a word she
just left the room and he obediently
followed this was the very first
casualty of a containment breach that
would go on to claim the lives of 43
members of scp foundation personnel
several male members of the staff
experience what can only be described as
a descent into violent insanity turning
on fellow members of personnel and
committing murder largely through the
act of strangulation a female mobile
task force was brought in to deal with
this rapidly escalating situation the
brainwashed staff members were
relatively easy to neutralize given the
superior training of the mtf compared to
on-site staff but the being that did
this to them would be a considerably
more challenging foe
scp-029 the daughter of shadows an
extremely violent and dangerous ketter
class anomaly she was still loose on the
site and that meant nobody was safe the
mtf prowled the hallways in three-person
squads while another small detachment
headed to the maintenance and security
rooms they couldn't rely on the on-site
guards for any help on this one
considering half the brainwashed
murderers they just terminated had
formerly been sight guards one of the
squads finally encountered scp-029 in
the dark hallway and engaged her in
violent combat the daughter of shadows
is an incredibly formidable opponent
she's significantly stronger than a
non-anomalous human being she's highly
resistant to most forms of damage and
her reflexes are around four times
faster than some of the fastest recorded
non-anomalous human reflexes in other
words she can shrug off bullets and
seems to be one of the world's most
proficient stranglers you really don't
want to have to engage with scp-029 in a
physical fight one of the three mtf
operatives attempting to subdue scp-029
was already dead her neck practically
caved in from the force of a squeeze
when the lights finally came back on
while the foundation didn't know a great
deal about the daughter of shadows they
were aware of one thing her anomalous
powers were significantly weakened when
faced with bright light the operatives
in the maintenance and security rooms
had turned up the lights in the hallway
to their maximum brightness stunning the
daughter of shadows just long enough for
the mobile task force to converge and
through their combined strength and
resources subdue and contain the
creature again she was swiftly delivered
back to her high security containment
chamber and locked away once more the
containment chamber is sealed with a
triple air lock and powerful flood
lights on the walls keep the creature in
a constant state of stark illumination a
truly foolish mistake by security
officer walker who'd been shot to death
not even an hour prior by the mobile
task force had caused this particularly
deadly containment breach ignoring very
specific foundation containment
protocols out of his own sense of
foolish morbid curiosity he'd strayed
too close to scp-029 containment chamber
and been dragged into her terrible
thrall considering the vast array of
potential world or even universe enders
on the scp foundation's roster
scp-029 is far from the most dangerous
anomaly out there but she's proven time
and time again to be one of the most
problematic to contain and due to her
incredibly violent temperament and
dangerous anomalous abilities every time
scp-029 does breach containment a lot of
innocent foundation employees are bound
to die the daughter of shadows a
self-given name that seems to be
inspired by the fact her skin
pigmentation is 80 true black has a
seemingly unquenchable bloodlust though
ironically she despises the actual
shedding of blood
scp-029 has been shown to be capable of
improvising a weapon out of almost any
object truly the macgyver of murder but
she will always kill in a manner that
causes no blood to be spilled hence her
preference for strangulation she also
has the ability to brainwash male
victims into committing murder on her
behalf by making them believe that she
is some form of goddess despite showing
clear sentience and sound technical
reasoning it's impossible to reason with
the daughter of shadows as she has no
compassion or better judgment to appeal
to her requests for a bed a blanket some
books and some clothes have all been
denied due to the pretty justifiable
belief that all these requests are just
a pretense to get security lowered
around her this harsh treatment actually
led to an official complaint by dr erica
brodin it stated this is ridiculous the
girl can't even have clothes we are not
animals that are cover herself dr sophia
light posted an official reply saying dr
boudin you are granted permission to
deliver clothes to scp-029
life sadly punished dr bodine for her
compassion the daughter of shadows
murdered her with the very clothes she
brought in to keep it warm and the tape
of her grisly death is now used as an
educational tool for anyone assigned to
scp-029
a grim reminder of the real and present
danger that the creature poses to anyone
in its vicinity because of the nature of
the anomaly and her abilities the
foundation takes a very hands-off
approach to interacting with her guards
are posted outside and not even food is
brought into the chamber as scp-029
seems to be able to survive just fine
without it at this point you're probably
wondering what is this thing really and
how did the scp foundation find it in
the first place we'll tell you all we
can about that but be warned
scp-029 is also linked to one of the
darkest things the foundation has ever
needed to do in the pursuit of keeping
an anomaly contained it all began with
what seemed like an incredibly random
assault on agent ramachandran an scp
foundation field operative stationed in
rural india the assailant attempted to
strangle agent ramachandran before being
quickly subdued because of the
strangeness of the event the agent began
a weeks-long investigation into who the
man was and why he'd commit this attack
that sent agent ramachandran down a
frightening rabbit hole towards a small
but incredibly violent local cult the
men claimed to be thuggies a
historically frightening group of roving
robbers and murderers who terrorize
parts of india throughout its long
history and what's more this particular
sect of thugs seem to worship the
daughter of shadows as a kind of
earth-bound demigod they believe that if
they made 1 million sacrifices to the
violence-loving entity it would bring
about the end of the world however they
also believe that only sacrifices
committed via strangulation would count
towards their million soul total the
foundation amassed a small invasion
force to infiltrate and take down their
mountainside fortress from within
naturally they were met with
considerable violent resistance which
sadly caused the death of agent
ramachadron the very reason we were able
to locate the daughter of shadows in the
first place but in the end the
foundation prevailed the thuggies were
either slaughtered or repelled and the
foundation operatives discovered scp-029
within the temple along with a huge
number of corpses believed to be the
cult's prior victims given how dark it
was inside the temple the daughter of
shadows was a formidable level of power
she killed and brainwashed several of
the agents who attempted to contain her
but was eventually subdued and
transported back to the nearest secure
containment site one of the most
infamous incidents that scp-029 is
associated with happened around seven
years after her capture the level of
dark pigmentation on her skin was
beginning to increase prompting concern
among researchers when they asked her
what was happening she simply said that
her followers were on the move again
prompting concern that 029's thuggy cult
was due for another resurgence knowing
how dangerous this cult could be the scp
foundation decided that drastic action
would be needed to deal with them this
time when they eventually located
members of the cult they began tracking
them and gathering intelligence they
discovered that a mass gathering of the
entire cult was imminent on a day that
they believed to be holy the foundation
waited until then to strike when the
cult was gathered in worship the
foundation conducted an aerial strike
killing them all in an instant the
second this happened the daughter of
shadow sat bolt upright and screamed for
several hours mourning the death of her
beloved followers she learned a hard
lesson that day while she and her
methods were undeniably brutal when the
situation called for it the scp
foundation could be plenty brutal as
well
since this incident
scp-029 has increased her efforts to
escape perhaps so she can get the jump
on building a brand new cult now go
check out
scp-1179 centralian fire demon and
scp-2845 alien god crash lands on earth
the deer for more fascinating and
terrifying entities from the scp
foundation